[Music]
now I for one I'm a strong believer in
small-town justice so here's what I did
I visited with the sheriff of Johnson
County which is located 50 miles south
of Dallas to see if I had what it takes
to become a County deputy the rare
privilege of standing here with Sheriff
Bob Alford of Johnson County Sheriff
good to see you mr. O'Brien
my pleasure okay so are you going to
deputize me today if I pass the test if
you pass the test Oh Conan do you mind
the background on yourself do you have a
criminal record have you committed a
felony
I stole a wheelchair about six years ago
did you need transportation or I just
started running I thought it would be
funny if the person came out and their
wheelchair was gone it's not so funny
at least you see the error of your ways
so that's supposed you're right I will
eventually stop doing it to a big deputy
of course you're expected to step in
there and help him is necessary or can I
just watch from the car don't you have
got to get your hands dirty you got to
eat the beans
where are the jeans get in there I'm
sorry say that again
where are the jeans wear the jeans get
in there with the guy okay the third
part doesn't run we have a training
period you have to go through before you
actually drive and what we call the lead
officer today you're gonna be the backup
you're starting me a backup yes Sheriff
all due respect I'm a celebrity yes sir
I'm from Hollywood yes sir so why am i
starting with backup you're a celebrity
you're from Hollywood yeah
like it to carry a gun yes sir you can
be carrying a 6-hour 45 caliber
if you pass God did that couldn't I'm
not very I don't know a lot about guns
did you just fire that gun because oh
that's just you're just decocking it yes
I was D cocked once I'm sure this is the
simulator there be different scenarios
set up on the screen so you have to make
that call
can I shoot this guy or do I talk him
down or did let him go and catch him
later okay you and your partner are
responding to the silent alarm at a
local bank you stayed here and I'll
check out inside it's probably just
another false alarm
okay she's very attractive
walking in there I don't know the back
you don't run any risks okay I got him
why didn't you shoot Jim
you shot an innocent civilian this guy
just whooped your partner's fixing the
book view and you're just standing there
well first of all he was wearing a
t-shirt that said world peace and I'll
check out inside it's probably another
false alarm
[Music]
with anything wrong with your reaction I
may have shot the woman how many parts
the bank I don't think there was
anything left in the scene but you know
we did get the bad guy we did he was
fleeing yeah he was not a threat when he
turned and draws the gun he's a threat
yeah hit me wait till he shoots it means
all right no thank you
you don't like to do I like to take out
the trash before it starts to stink
Jerry I won't get in front of a jury law
doesn't touch me
celebrities do not pay for their crimes
yeah we're all that list of celebrities
that got away with it and go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
question yes sir how many people in this
town know kung-fu
we're running across is a kung fu master
I'd like to be deputized as quickly as
possible given a gun and allowed to run
the streets all right
Conan O'Brien do you solemnly swear that
will faithfully execute the duties of
the office of deputy sheriff of the
state of Texas
[Applause]
you